lindsey graham is now threatening riots
if donald trump is indicted
now this is being reported as lindsey
graham
predicts riots if donald trump gets
indicted but the reality is that lindsey
graham is threatening the riots it's his
followers who would be doing the rioting
now
lindsay could say
right wingers would never do that
but he's not saying that right wingers
is saying
our side will riot in the street if
donald trump is indicted and it is
indeed a threat check this out this is
an interview that lindsay gave to fox
news over the weekend
very very quickly garnering millions of
views and understand
this is a threat
he is saying you'd better not do it and
i'm going to give you the two reasons
why he's saying this say this
if there's a prosecution of donald trump
for mishandling classified information
after the clinton debacle which you
presided over and did a hell of a good
job there'll be riots in the streets
right there will be riots in the streets
now first and foremost i thought right
wingers never rioted remember it was blm
that does the rioting it was antifa that
does the rioting it might have even been
people pretending to be trumpets but
really left wingers on january 6 who
were dressed up
as trumpists and had trump stuff on
their social media dating back years but
it was all a ruse they were really left
wingers because right wingers would
never ever ever riot and now lindsay is
saying there will be riots if trump is
indicted this is what they do
lindsay is planting the seeds when he
says i predict that there might be riots
he is getting right wingers to think
about what will we do if there is an
indictment of trump now when we learned
about the search warrant being served at
mar-a-lago trump has started showing up
in large groups at mar-a-lago and
elsewhere and it didn't get violent
fortunately but it was very clear that
they are willing to get out there in the
real world well now you've got lindsay
saying i predict that there will be
rights really lindsay who will be doing
it it's not going to be black lives
matter or antifa it's going to be
trumpists so they are now planting the
seed now afterwards they might say it
was antifa anyway
you know they they love these dystopian
headlines portland oregon has been
eliminated from the map after antifa
detonated a suitcase nuke that never
what are you talking about that never
happened portland's fine portland's
still there
um and so here's the the goal of what
lindsey graham is saying there's two
um purposes to lindsey graham coming out
and saying this the first purpose is
if we start sending a signal to the
justice department that it will get very
violent and very hectic and very riotous
and dystopian in the streets of america
if trump is indicted maybe we can
prevent an indictment altogether so
that's like the priority number one
would be maybe i can start sending these
signals and trump won't get indicted at
all the justice department might say
there's too much fallout there's too
much risk we're not going to do it
the second part of it of course is the
obvious one which is start to get the
political allies and the right wingers
comfortable with the idea that it would
be correct for there to be violence in
the streets because if people like
lindsay and others start saying
this would be so unfair
this would be so bad this would be so
improper if trump were to be indicted
that it would obviously lead to riots in
the streets they're essentially
normalizing the writing
and whether the idea there is
to maybe prevent the right wingers from
getting in as much trouble as they did
after january 6th or whatever the point
is start to normalize the idea that if
this happened
violence would be appropriate
that is another element of this it's
stochastic terrorism in a way which
we've talked about before they're really
very dangerously on the line of straight
up encouraging the violence but
understand that the headline is bs the
headline lindsey graham predicts
violence no no lindsey graham is
threatening violence lindsey graham is
promising violence and he seems to be
saying it would be justified and that's
an extraordinarily scary place to be
when one of 100 sitting senators is
planting the idea of violence in the
minds of a group of people
that are willing to do violence and
property destruction and everything we
saw on january 6. really scary stuff
we'll have this clip of lindsay on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
let's talk about vpn's virtual private
networks even if you're using incognito
mode on your browser if you're not using
a vpn everything you do online can be
recorded by your internet provider and
that is permanent because they're
selling it search engines social media
companies are also tracking your every
move you only need one thing to protect
yourself from all of it private internet
access one of our sponsors it's a vpn
it's simple you take a moment and you
download it you turn it on and you're
protected and you stay protected and
that's it vpns can also keep your
connection secure from hackers important
every time you check your bank account
or 401k or pension otherwise it can all
be out in the open private internet
access never records or stores user data
they've even proven this policy multiple
times in court their software is open
source to show that there's no data
being logged
this transparency is why private
internet access
is the vpn i use and my audience gets 82
off so you can stay protected for just
two dollars and 11 cents a month plus
you'll get three months free go to
private internet access dot com slash
pacman the link is down below